d'abord qu'elle est engagée qu'elle est
impliquée qu'elle cherche l'accord
puisque c'est sa mission
euh nous nous avons un texte qui est
celui du du Sénat entre parenthèses
heureusement là encore qu'il y a un
texte au Sénat et je vois qu'aujourd'hui
tout le monde dit le texte du Sénat
merveilleux formidable moi je me
souviens de ce qui s'est passé il y a
quelques semaines vous aussi
certainement il fallu bagarrer pour
qu'il y ait un texte hein de la même
façon au moment des retraites
heureusement qu'il y avait le texte du
Sénat donc
une fois de plus le Sénat a montré qu'il
était indispensable dans le
fonctionnement des institutions surtout
avec la configuration de l'Assemblée
nationale donc on peut trouver un accord
on a regardé les points difficiles laame
par exemple
Amu voilà l'aide médicale euh ça peut
faire l'objet d'un texte séparé en début
d'année donc ça ça pourrait être le
compromis on le sort du le projet de
immigration et on fait une réformme ma
part en début d'année prochaine un des
éléments du compromis si un engagement
du gouvernement pour dire que c'est
parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle de
cavalier législatif c'està-dire de de
textes qui n'ont pas leur place dans le
texte immigration on pourrait considérer
qu'il y a un débat
accepter mais c'est pas le seul un texte
qui pourrait être enfin partie du texte
qui pourrait être considéré comme un
cavalier législatif on parle aussi du
code de la nationalité ou encore les
prestations sociales aux étrangersà il y
a un certain nombre de points qu'on va
considérer comme irritant pour
l'Assemblée nationale et où nous sommes
disposés pour ce qui est de la majorité
sénatoriale à discuter de ces ces
différents points pour essayer de tendre
la main à nos collègues de
l'Assemblée